salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
alors aujourd'hui on est entre le Lot et
l'Aveyron dans le fleuve lot on est avec
des abonnés qui nous ont rejoint parce
qu'ils avaient un super spot dans lequel
ils ont trouvé deux armes donc on s'est
dit pourquoi pas on va aller tester ça
alors on est avec Alex et son fils
Gaëtan donc c'est parti pour la pêche il
y a star bien entendu et Romain et Mika
donc depuis combien de temps
[Musique]
de demain
ma première arme proche j'ai mis au
moins 6 mois à la faire pardon la
première
regardez-moi cet abonné chanceux les
gars premier lancer
alors ça alors ça c'est non c'est pas
silex c'est un pistolet on appelle ça de
poche un coup
qui est rechargement par la bouche mais
c'est magique comment il fait c'est pas
possible regardez moi ça l'abonné
il est en super état et en plus il est
encore en bon état bien
restaurable aussi
1850 quand même
pour qu'on le reste donc merci à lui
ça tu mets en fait tu mets juste une
amorce en haut tu mets la poudre et la
balle installer des trucs
il a trouvé ça c'est fou c'est fou par
contre la pêche à la main c'est pas trop
énorme dans les endroits comme ça à
chaque fois c'est c'est de la chance
alors là on est sur bloqué sur quelque
chose de très gros donc on va mettre
tous les bras je pense
vous avez tout le toutes les racines
avec bien joué bien joué
joué bon ben voilà belle personne avait
raison sur le pronostic voilà encore un
très gros morceau
et vous êtes prêt allez
c'est comme une [ __ ] d'amarrage
il y a pas un entraînement là
avec encore du câble d'acier autour
allez
je peux vous dire
[Musique]
bien joué
totalement fini il y a du poil Mathis
pour faire la muscu dans le garage
il y a plein de choses ici mais
difficile d'accès
il y a plein de trucs
alors on a
une cuillère
en bon état
on a essayé inoxydable je rappelle qu'il
y a des acides auxiliales qui sont
aimantés ensuite on a cette énorme
machin heureusement c'est vide
heureusement c'est pas de la fonte ouais
sûrement le cadre de mobylette et s'il y
avait pas si c'est Orange là dommage
quand on n'est pas amené la machette je
vous garantie que
les autres quoi
mais pas beaucoup
c'est sportif aujourd'hui
les professionnels reconnaîtront je sais
pas à quoi ça correspond
qu'est-ce que c'est un appareil
qu'est-ce que c'est
ça
c'est un vieux
là
ok
il y a plein de trucs là mais je me bats
avec les plantes mais il y a plein de
trucs
ah mais là tu vois c'est un spot où il
jette et j'étais dans les années 70-80
quoi
[Musique]
en vrai on pourrait
ah ouais direct
moi cette équipe de pêcheurs allemands
en haut de leur but
il est mort
allez faut trouver le couteau sinon
personne ne mange
ah oui pour faire des petits trous
là si c'est quelque chose de bien vous
êtes obligés de déposer le petit pouce
bleu il y a quelque chose
bon en vrai en vrai de vrai ça passe
salut non c'est pas une nuit
à la prochaine fois on vient en TER
[Musique]
belle pêche de Alex le temps il commence
à être pas mal sachant qu'on en a un peu
partout
en tout cas ici on est sur une sorte de
dépotoir des années 70
[Musique]
on va glisser on est
donc là regardez-moi ce passage secret
on est dans le pont regardez comment il
marche pas
il a peur de rien
c'est bien
et bien tiens grand bébé
qu'est-ce que c'est rasta pourquoi tu
regardes à l'aise comme ça
à l'intérieur
c'est impossible
d'un coup sec à l'intérieur il est
encore propre franchement
si tu veux
il est parfait il est magnifique
[Musique]
[Rires]
troisième spot de la journée vous êtes
chauds
coquin tu étais où coquin
sous le pont ça m'a l'air bien rempli
on va se plaint ici
je sais pas toi
est-ce que ça ce serait pas des barres
de morceaux de pompe ça c'est un guidon
de petit vélo pour enfant
ouais c'est un morceau de manivelle tout
autour ah oui d'accord qu'est-ce qu'il a
trouvé Alex
ici c'est rare oh magnifique
ah ouais très beau mais toi tu aimes
bien les couteaux en plus
[Musique]
le coin est très sympa
il y a quelques nuages mais ça va j'aime
bien la forme de la maison en face
regarde c'est original
la force de chez nous ils ont trouvé
quoi du coup un beau la gueule
je cours plus vite
qu'est-ce que c'est
une blague
c'est une blague
c'est quand même une sacrée qualité de
merde
est-ce que c'est carrément artisanal du
Lot moi je pense c'est une blague du lot
qu'est-ce qu'on a ici
c'est un levier et ça c'est une hache
regarde ça donc c'est une sorte de
levier
ils ont plus cette forme cela
plus cette forme
ah oui 72 mais c'est encore mieux ouais
72 vas-y doucement
1972 moi j'aurais dit carrément
les panneaux anciens comme ça ils sont
très rares
tu as quel âge super
salut ça va et vous
[Applaudissements]
pas
de missile un V1
là non des anciens exemplaires vous êtes
bloqués
je sais pas ce que c'est ce truc et ça
fait une heure qu'il m'embête
morceau de barrière peut-être
un câble téléphone ou électrique non
téléphonique
allez sur le poteau avec allez je te
filme
un cadavre un cadavre un cadavre
il y a une barrière il y a une barrière
je crois avec
une barrière
c'est bon
on va libérer le câble
ça n'avait rien à faire dans l'eau alors
romain qui vient de faire un autoradio
avec tous les branchements
il est pas jeune
il est pas jeune du tout
ah tu es dans le vintage là avec ton
autoradio
et le reste encore donc on reviendra
peut-être regarder la team est rincée
tout le monde est en mode repos même
Instagram
donc on va vous montrer ce qu'on a
trouvé dans le camion il y a de tout de
très belles trouvailles qu'on va essayer
de restaurer pour d'autres vidéos dites
le nous en commentaire si vous voulez
qu'on les restaurateur
la caméra
voilà le résultat de la journée
très grosse pêche encore là il y a du
poids